thank you everyone for attending this
talk today i will be talking about tide
harness results for training depth 2
radio networks
at least i work with serbia goel adam
clivens
and daniel reichmann
let us start by recalling the definition
of neural networks
neural network take in inputs here we
denote them by x1 and x2
so on and so forth to xn each of them is
a real number sometimes we also write
x to denote the vector x 1 x 2 so on to
x
n for privity a neural network can have
multiple layers and each layer can have
multiple nodes
each node can have an edge to each of
the node
from the previous layer for example
the node shown here has an edge from
each of the input node
associated with each edge is
a weight here we denote it by wi
which is a real number the input
to the node is the weighted
average of the input specifically the
input to this node shown here
would be w1 x1 plus w2 x2
so on and so forth plus w and xn
this input is passed through the
activation
function of the node we'll be more
specific about the activation function
in a moment but for now you can think of
it as some
function from real numbers to real
numbers
this activation function give the output
to
the node and as i said earlier there can
be multiple nodes in each layer
which give us multiple outputs from that
layer
these outputs can then be used as input
to the next layer and we can build
multiple layers on top of each other
now in many of the recent breakthrough
practical results of neural network the
neural networks that i use
have many layers and hence the name deep
learning
however from the theoretical perspective
even
relatively simple and shallow neural
networks
are still not completely understood
and thus in this work we focus on a
pretty
simple class of neural networks which is
the class of depth to fully connected
neural networks
this means that there are only two
layers on top of the
input layer and furthermore each node
has an eighth edge from all the nodes
from the previous layer
and moreover the final output layer only
has
one node meaning that the output is just
a real number
now as the title of this talk suggests
we also limit ourselves only to
relu activation function so the rayleigh
activation
is a function that takes in some real
number c
and output the maximum between c and
zero
and for brevity here we write this
function as
bracket c subscript plus
now the top layer that we are
considering here
is using the identity activation
function
we just mean that it outputs exactly the
input
which is the weighted sum from the
previous layer
throughout this talk we used k to denote
the number of nodes
in the middle layer and we used
w superscript j to denote the weight
vector
of the edges coming into the jth node in
this layer
for the node at the top we use a1
a2 and so on to ak to denote the weights
of the edges coming into it
with this notion in mind such a neural
network can be viewed as a function
that takes in an n-dimensional vector x
and output the sum of i from 1 to k
of a i times the rayleigh of
w i dot x
we call a class of such neural networks
or such
functions as k relu it's worth noting
here that
the weights at the top a1 a2 to ak
can be assumed with our loss of
generality to be either plus 1 or minus
1.
the reason is that the scales of these
weights
can be pushed down to the wi's instead
now in this work we are interested in
the problem of
training or learning such k-relu
networks
let us start with the formal problem the
training problem
in this problem we are given a set s of
samples
x and the label y and our goal is to
find a k
rayleigh that fit these samples as well
as possible
specifically we want it so that if we
pass
x through to our network the output
should be as close to y as possible
more formally we would like to find a k
relu f that minimizes the loss function
between the output of the k relu
on x and the given level y
for some loss function
and recall here that our unknowns are
the weights
a1 to ak and w1 2wk
in this work we only consider one loss
function
which is the square loss which is a
pretty
popular loss function let's just take
the difference between the two number
and square them
there are two cases uh that we'll be
discussing
regarding these problems the first one
is the realizable case
so this is the case where there is a
promise that
some unknown k relu achieves
zero error meaning that its output is
exactly equals to y
always and another case is the
agnostic case where this statement is
not true
so even the best k relu
doesn't achieve zero error
so that's the training problem now we
also consider
the learning problem which is almost the
same as the training problem
except that there is now an unknown
distribution d
and our samples are drawn independently
at random
from this distribution d and the loss is
now with respect
to the underlying distribution d instead
of
the given samples now for those of you
who are familiar with learning theory
we are only considering proper learning
here
meaning that the function that we would
like as an
output is only allowed to be a k
relu so you cannot output an arbitrary
function
notice here that the learning problem is
harder than the training problem
specifically if you set the distribution
d
to be the uniform distribution on s then
you can take any
learning algorithm and turn it into a
training algorithm as well
what this means is that for the purpose
of giving an algorithm
it suffice to only give an algorithm for
the learning problem
whereas for the purpose of giving a
hardness
result it suffice to only prove hardness
for the training problem
finally before we state our results
since our result will be quantitative
on the additive error as well we will
need
some normalizing assumption specifically
we will assume that
each wi has norm at most one and the
input vector x also has norm at most one
and these two implies that the output
y's
are between minus k and k
so with that in mind we can now state
our results
which can be divided into three groups
first is np hardness results second is
algorithms
and third is tight running time lower
bounds
our first result is that even
training a single relu is already np
hard
and in fact even minimizing the loss
is np hard to approximate to within an
almost polynomial in n
factor and note here that this np
harness
only holds in the agnostic setting
and this is not a coincidence because if
we are in the realizable setting
then the problem of training a single
relu can be formulated as a linear
program
which of course can be solved
efficiently
on the other hand even if we are in the
realizable setting
if there are multiple values we show
that this is np-hat
specifically for any constant k greater
than or equal to
2 we show that training k relu is np
hard even in the realizable case
i would like to note here that there are
quite a few independent and parallel
works
that prove results similar to us here
specifically
they at l uh also show that trending a
single relu is np hard
bakshi at l also showed that training
two relu is np hard although they did
not show
that training k relu is np hard for k
greater than or equals to three
and finally move at l show np harness
of training for an architecture is
slightly different than us
specifically they consider one where the
top note is also a relu node
and not an identity or additive node as
we are using here
now our np harness results show us that
even when there is one two or only a few
relu nodes
the problem of minimizing the loss is
already
hard for multiplicative approximation
however we can show that for additive
approximation we can get
quite good algorithms first
we show that in the agnostic setting
there is an algorithm
for learning k relu to within an
additive
error of epsilon that runs in times
exponential
in k to the fifth over epsilon squared
times polynomial in n and k
when it's realizable case this running
time can be
spread out further specifically the
exponent
goes down from k fifth over epsilon
squared to
roughly k cubed over epsilon
it is interesting here that the
realizable case seems to be easier
than the agnostic case since our
algorithm for the former is faster
than the ladder and hence it's natural
to ask
whether this difference is intrinsic or
whether we should be able to come up
with
faster algorithms for agnostic learning
it turns out that we can show that this
difference is intrinsic
specifically we can show tight running
time lower bound
for both agnostic and realizable setting
with respect to epsilon to set our
running time lower bounds we have to
first recall
some complexity theoretical hypothesis
the first is the exponential time
hypothesis or eth
which states that no 2 to the leader of
n time algorithm
can solve the three set problem where n
denote
the number of variables in other words
this is
asserting that the brute force due to
the end time algorithm that
just goes through each of the assignment
and check whether is satisfiable
is optimal up to the constant in the
exponent
we will also be using a strengthening of
eth
called gap eth which states that
no two to the leader of end time
algorithm can distinguish between
a fully satisfiable three set instead
and one which is
not only not satisfiable but not even
0.99 satisfiable meaning that every
assignment violates at least one percent
of the clauses
so under the gap exponential hypothesis
we can show that for any constant k
greater than or equal to
two the uh training k
rayleigh problem cannot be solved in
times exponential with little of one
over epsilon
times polene in k
where again epsilon is the additive
error
note here that in terms of epsilon this
meshes
with the algorithm that we give in the
realizable case
but it remains an interesting open
question to determine the exact
dependency
of decay all right so that's the
realizable setting let us now move on to
the agnostic setting
for the agnostic running time lower
bound you need
a different and new complexity theoretic
hypothesis
to state it let us recall the densest
case sub graph or dks
problem where we are given an undirected
graph t
on n vertices and a positive integer k
and the goal is to find k vertex
subgraph of d
with maximum number of edges
our hypothesis which we call gap eth for
density k subgraph or gravitation for
dks
states that no 2 to the leader of n time
algorithm
can approximate the in this case of
graph to within
a constant factor now
honestly this is a very strong
hypothesis but it
also seems somewhat plausible and one
reason is that
if you assume that certain random csps
are hard to refute in sub-exponential
time
then the gap eth for dks would follow
on the other hand the bad news is that
no np harness of approximation for dks
is
known even for say 1.1
factor so it seems very hard to prove
and possibly out of reach of the current
techniques
okay so using this admittedly strong
assumption
of gap eth for dks we can show that
even for agnostic training of one relu
with additive error epsilon
it cannot be done in time exponential in
little
of 1 over epsilon square times poly and
k
now one way epsilon square here in the
exponent is
tight because it matches with our
algorithm and moreover
this give us separation between agnostic
and realizable
learning because in the latter we can
get it
in exponential in one over epsilon if k
is constant so those are
all our results for the rest of this
talk i will go through
each of them and describe at a high
level how it's proved
we'll start with the algorithms so i
copy the results here on the right
and i also copy the definition of k relu
here on the left
so we'll be using a simple
but very nice training algorithm of
aurora at l
which works as follow for each input
sample
x y we guess the signs of
w1 dot x and so on and so forth to wk
dot
x furthermore we also guessed the
a1 so on and so forth to a k and recall
here that
each ai we can assume to be in plus
minus one
and finally the observation here is that
once we
guess the signs and also the a i's
each sine corresponds to just one
additional linear
constraint and after this casing
the f x is just a linear combination of
x
without the rayleigh function anymore
so now we can formulate our problem as a
convex program and solve it
efficiently now
in terms of the number of cases since we
have to guess k
signs for each sample we will have to
guess
roughly k times m sines
where m denote the number of samples so
this means that
the running time of our algorithm is
exponential
in k times m and times the polynomial
in the problem size so at a glance
this might be a not very good algorithm
because the running time depends
exponentially in the number of samples
but it turns out that this is not an
issue
and what comes in to help us here is
generalization bounds
for those of you who haven't seen
generalization bounds before
generalization bounds just say that when
you solve
a learning problem you only have to
sample a certain number of samples and
train them well
and then you immediately get also
a low error for the underlying
distribution
and specifically for the agnostic case
uh it follows from the work of bartlett
and mendelssohn
that k to the fourth over epsilon square
samples
suffices so plugging in
m equals to this number into
our running time on the left we
immediately get
our agnostic algorithm
for the realizable case it's known that
the number of samples required
can be improved specifically three bo at
l
show that only k square or epsilon
sample suffice
so plugging in this bound we immediately
get the improved running time
low bound for the realizable case so
that's it
that's the entire proof of our
algorithms
now let us move on to the np hardness
result
so i copy the results here on the left
for both the agnostic and realizable
cases
let us start with the agnostic case so
here i recall that we are
going to prove that training a single
relu is np hard
and let me copy the single red loo here
which is just
a1 times w1 dot x pass through a relu
and notice here that uh since a1 can be
only plus minus one
and there is only a single a1 we can
assume without a lot
of generality that is just one and
for convenient we will write the b1 as w
since there is only
one vector w
so our np hardness reduction will start
from the
set cover problem recall that in set
cover
there is a universe which i denote by
m and there are subsets t1
t2 and so on to tn of m and our goal is
to
find the smallest number of subsets
whose union
is the entire universe m
to reduce this problem to the trending a
single relu
we set the dimension of the
input to the rayleigh small n to be
equals to the
big n which is the number of subsets in
the set cover
and review each subset as a coordinate
now before we describe the reduction
let us note here that the intended
solution here
would be to set a coordinate i to 1
even only if ti belongs to the optimal
set cover
and if it doesn't belong to the optimal
set cover then the coordinate will be
set to zero
so with that in mind let's continue with
the construction
of the samples and the easiest way to
describe this is
to view each sample x y as a constraint
that relu of the build.x is equals to y
the two types of constraints will be
adding here
the first is the element constraint
specifically for each element j
we create many copies of the following
form
the rayleigh of 1 minus sum of the view
i
over or i such that t i contains
j is equals to zero
the point about this constraint is that
in the intended solution
since we set all coordinate i for which
t i belongs to the set cover to be one
we have ensured that in this sum at
least one of the term is one
so the left hand side will be zero and
this constraint will always be satisfied
in the intended solution the second type
of constraints that we'll be adding
are the subset constraints so for each
subset
t i will create a constraint that
relu of delta minus w i
is equals to delta where delta is some
small positive real number
the point here is that this constraint
is satisfied
only when the view is less than or equal
to zero
in other words it is violated when ti
is selected in the set cover
now due to time constraint we will not
be going through the
entire proof here but the rough idea is
that
the element constraint ensures that the
selected set is a valid set cover
whereas the subset constraint ensures
that we are
picking as few set as possible and hence
this is indeed the set cover problem
all right so that's conclude the high
level overview of the reduction and the
proof
that training a single relu is np hard
in the agnostic case
before we go forward let me note here
that this proof doesn't directly
give the hardness of approximation uh to
within almost polynomial factor
yet and the reason is that set cover
itself can be
approximate within log m factor
so to get the claim hardness
approximation
we have to reduce from a different
problem which is a generalization of the
set cover
problem called the minimum monotone
circuit satisfiability
this problem is known to be hard to
approximate to almost polynomial
factor and by generalizing this
reduction
we can prove a similar statement for the
agnostic training of a single relu
all right so now that we are done with
the agnostic case let us now move on to
the
realizable case and i'm copying the
definition of k relu here for
convenience
it turns out that in this case wu had
already
proved an np harness for training k relu
in the realizable case where k is
greater than or equal to 2 before
except that his proof only works when
we assume that a1 and a2 and so on to ak
are all equals to 1. thus the only thing
we have to do is to handle the case
where
a1 and so on to ak can be negative
and to do this we use a new gadget which
is just a set of points
such that these points can only be
realizable by k
relu with a1 and so on to ak
being all equal to one and by adding
these points to the reduction of wu
we immediately translate his result to
the case where
all the a's may not just be plus one
we have completed our discussion on the
np harness results
let us now move on to the last group of
results the tight running time lower
bounds
we can start here with the realizable
case
fortunately for us our np
harness reduction that we just discussed
together
with the known harness or approximating
k coloring of patreon
already imply a lower bound of
exponential of little one over epsilon
for the case of realizable setting under
the gap eth assumption
so we're done here unfortunately
the agnostic case is not as simple
specifically our set cover reduction
only give a lower bound
of exponential 1 over epsilon instead of
1 over epsilon squared that we want
and this is not a coincidence in fact
whenever the intended solution is almost
correct
then there is actually an algorithm with
running time
exponential in one over epsilon instead
of one over epsilon square
and i will not be too specific here
about what it means to be
almost correct but you can think of it
as having a very very small
loss
so from this what can we conclude
if we want to prove a lower bound of 1
over epsilon square
then even our intended solution cannot
be almost correct
we will now describe our reduction from
lenses k subgraph
that satisfies this property
so we view each vertex as a coordinate
and the intended solution is to set a
coordinate to 1 over square root k
even only if the corresponding vertex
belongs to the optimal subgraph
note that since the subgraph contains k
vertices
the intended solution has num1 as
desired
in terms of the samples once again we
can describe them as constraints
the first type of constraint is
cardinality constraints
for each vertex j we create
the constraint relu of wj minus
0.5 over square root k equals to 1.
now note here that since most of the w
are
very small compared to 1 this constraint
will mostly be violated even in the
intended solution
and this indeed aligns with our
intuition earlier that even the intended
solution
cannot be almost correct
furthermore among all weight vectors w
of num1
the loss with respect to the cardinality
constraints is minimized
exactly when k coordinates are set to 1
over square root k
in other words these cardinality
constraints
are incentivizing us to pick k vertices
and not more the second type of
constraint is the age constraint
for every hij we create the following
sample so relu of wi plus wj
minus 0.75 over square root k is equals
to 1.
now note here that unless
both vertices i and j are selected in
our subgraph
the left hand side will evaluate to zero
but if both of them are selected then
the left hand side will
evaluate to a non-zero number in the
latter case
we will be incurring smaller loss
in other words these age constraints are
incentivizing us
to pick vertices that induce a lot of
edges
i will not have time to go into more
detail here
but this reduction indeed give us the
exponential 1 over
epsilon square running time lower bound
for the agnostic case
as desired
all right so that's all the technical
stuff that i will talk about today
let me now conclude in this work we
study
the problem of training and learning
depth to reload networks
and we give simple learning algorithms
and
np hardness results and matching running
time low about
despite of our results there are still
several interesting open questions and
research directions
a concrete one is to obtain a tight
running time low bounce in terms of
k recall that our running time lower
bound is
tight in terms of epsilon but we do not
know what
should be the right dependency in terms
of k and it would be nice to figure this
out
another is to consider other loss
functions
in this work we only focus our study on
the square laws
but there are other laws that are used
in practice
and in theory as well such as absolute
loss function or the cross
enthalpy so our np harness
result especially for the realizable
setting
x10 to this loss function however it is
unclear
whether we can get tight running time
low bounce there as well
and it would be nice to understand these
questions
another interesting question here is to
consider
deeper neural networks as i stated at
the
beginning of the talk most of the neural
networks
used in practice are pretty deep much
deeper than two layers
so it would be interesting to prove
hardness for deep
networks in fact
we are not aware of any hardness result
even for depth 3
relu networks next it would be nice to
relax the assumption that we use
for proving the tight running time low
bound for the agnostic case
specifically currently we use the gap
eth for densest case subgraph assumption
so it would be nice to prove it under a
more believable assumption
such as the gap eth or the eth itself
finally it would also be interesting to
consider the
improper learning setting
recall that in improper learning we can
output any function
that doesn't have to be a k relu and in
this setting
corel and other show that
there is a faster algorithm
that beats even the running time lower
bound in the proper setting
in our work so what this mean is that
improper
learning probably give you more power in
this setting
and it would be nice to prove a matching
running time low bound
there as well and with that
thank you all very much for your
attention